the united nations says the war in
ukraine could worsen a global food
crisis leading to mass hunger and famine
lasting for years speaking at a major
u.n summit in new york secretary general
antonio guterres said russia's invasion
of ukraine was the latest factor driving
global food insecurity on top of the
pandemic and global warming guterres
said he was in intense contact with
russia and other countries to address
the situation
there is no effective solution to the
food crisis
without reintegrating ukraine's food
production as well as the food and
fertilizer products produced by russia
and belarus into world markets despite
the war
russia must permit the safe and secure
export of grains stored in ukrainian
ports
alternative transportation routes can be
explored even if we know that by itself
they will not be enough to solve the
problem
and russian food and fertilizers must
have unrestricted access to world
markets without indirect impediments
all right let's bring in max zander who
is in kiev max give us a sense of how
important ukraine is in the global food
supply chain
it is of huge importance let me let me
tell you that ukraine has been dubbed
the bread basket of europe so it's one
of the largest producers and export
exporters of agricultural exports such
as wheat or sunflower oil and corn
in 2020 alone ukraine was the fifth
largest exporter of of wheat in the
entire world so this has uh significant
consequences for the global food supply
chains and also a lot of the
humanitarian aid to some of the poorest
countries in africa and in the middle
east that comes from uh from ukraine so
also huge implications here
so what effect has the war had on food
production and exports
right so some of the farmers were
conscripted into military service some
some of the farms couldn't operate due
to fighting um the russians have
actually are still
targeting agricultural production such
as silos and storages but that being
said ukraine produces much more
agriculture products than it can consume
domestically and a lot of this stuff is
actually stuck in the country right now
cannot be exported usually a lot of it
would leave uh by sea um but the
russians control the sea of oz in the
east and the port of odessa on the west
is is being blocked so at the moment
there are roughly 90 million tons of
agriculture experts waiting to leave the
country and ukraine is losing roughly
170 million dollars a day
clearly a massive impact so what's being
done to address these issues
right so the un is negotiating with
russia and other key players such as
turkey but there's very little
information coming out of these talks at
the moment the eu is trying to help
trying to pitch in trying to find
alternative routes at the moment
so one option could be the smaller
river ports the new river port for
example close to odessa but that is
nowhere near the capacity of the
seaports so the most likely option or
the option that's being used at the
moment is is exporting by trains so uh
loading on on on trains cargo trains and
sending
the the wheats and other exports across
the borders into poland into slovakia
and to romania and to their respective
ports there but there are also some
obstacles there in the way because the
train system is not compatible between
uh ukraine and uh some of the eastern
european countries so there this also
creates some holdup so it's it's a lot
less than actually could be exported
through the ports
all right maxander reporting from keeve
thanks so much
now as we've been hearing the war has
drastically hampered exports via the
black sea and is exacerbating the global
food security crisis so now the romanian
port of constanza has become a vital hub
for grain shipments dw's jack parrock
reports now on the challenges that it's
facing
this ukrainian corn would never have
been here at the port of constanza
before russia's invasion
it would have been shipped out of the
now closed port of odessa 250 kilometers
up the black sea coast it's good for
business for the operators here but
there are concerns about capacity
the
next three weeks the romanian crop will
start to
come
in
we are
confident that we can manage also the
romanian quantity and ukrainian quantity
of grains we can maintain manage to
send them to the ship
but of course we cannot stop remaining a
harvest for the ukrainian port once this
vessel leaves port 210 000 tons of
ukrainian corn will have been shipped
out since the start of april
but that's just one percent of the 20
million tons of grain that needs to be
shifted in the next three months before
these ukrainian fields are harvested to
avoid major bottlenecks which could
cause it to rot
pretty much all of the corn that's
coming into the port of constanza is
from ukraine at the moment this boat is
headed from here though to rotterdam but
many of the vessels go to north africa
and the middle east and there are real
fears of an increase in food shortages
and famine if supply bottlenecks arise
the port authority says it's doing
everything it can we don't have other
choice water if i
i screaming and i hear everywhere it's
very easy to scream i don't i cannot do
nothing i cannot this is it's okay it's
hard time everybody this is a special
situation and everybody must accommodate
this situation find solution constanza
port has another problem though 700 of
these wagons lay rusting on the port's
underused train lines held in judicial
limbo following legal battles between
state and private entities the country's
transport minister says a new 40 million
euro project will renovate 95 romanian
train lines before the end of the year
partly to make switching wheels to
accommodate trains arriving from the
east which use wider tracks for 30 or 40
years these
tracks were abandoned so now we invest
in a lot in order
to
to modernize this line
the soviet type
of
lines and to come
directly in the
harbor
this really is a graveyard of these old
cargo carriages right now we're a few
hundred meters away from the port of
constanza and the plan is that this
won't only support with the ukrainian
shipments that are coming in but also
that it will help rejuvenate this area
for the future but in the short term
europe's approaching summer will only
mean more grains coming in
and with no end to the war in sight
pressure on the infrastructure here in
constanza is only set to pile on
you